Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so a lot of you
requested a video on Captain Marvel Kevin
Feige recently announced that she is going
to crush the rest of the avengers in terms
of power levels so I'll explain what's up
with that is been a lot of Captain Marvel
stuff in the news because of what's going
on in the comics and then was going on in
the movies.
You know what we should do it for actually
no big Marvel family photo we should introduce
the newest member of the Marvel family the
newest person joining us Captain Marvel herself
Brie Larson!
recently Kevin Feige did a really big interview
where he explained Captain Marvel is going
to be there most OP overpowered character
that they've ever done in a Marvel movie.
So far.
Now he was probably not talking about Thanos
or about Odin because the Odin force makes
out in one of the most powerful people in
the universe next to things like the living
tribunal.
Doctor strange shoutout or like they Enos
when he's wearing the infinity gauntlet, we
know were heading to infinity war, it's likely
that Thanos will assemble the gauntlet just
makes sense that she is the most powerful
avengers characters that they've introduced
next to the whole because technically the
hulk would be the most powerful character
but the things the movies have changed is
they've introduced the infinity gems in ways
that they don't appear in the comics so the
vision wields the mind gem.
It makes him vastly more powerful than comic
book vision, so the same thing will probably
end up happening with Captain Marvel.
There's just very few ways to make a human
character more powerful than someone wielding
an infinity gem.
So all actually explain because they did that
in the comics before secret wars Doctor doom
did not have an infinity gem, but he was as
powerful as someone wielding an infinity gauntlet
so that's kind of another thing but just to
talk about the movies one of the people this
writing the screenplay, Nicole Perlman she
was one of the people responsible for guardians
of the Galaxy getting turned into a movie
she already confirmed that they were changing
Captain Marvel's back story from the comics
so she gets tied up in a lot of pre-storyline
even though Marvel does have the Cree they
appear the guardians of the Galaxy movie they
sound like they still want to keep the Earth-based
avengers story separate from what's happening
in the guardians of the galaxy the Thor movies
in outer space.
So what will probably happen is is that Carol
Danvers will still be an Air Force colonel,
but she will somehow get tied up in the furor
of infinity war and gain her powers during
that movie via infinity gem recently during
the Civil War to storyline we've seen her
fighting Iron Man, but a lot of your like
what if she were to fight Thor like there
a lot of characters that aren't around for
her to fight the could probably put her on
her ass Thor does not have his hammer anymore.
There's a female version of Thor is like a
completely different situation but technically
Thor like forget Odin even Thor could put
comic book Captain Marvel on her, but there's
a big twist with Civil War two they still
have the final issue.
So even though they changed a lot of what's
going on with the characters, there's a lot
of weird Iron Man stuff happening in the comics
right now just wait till the end of December
beginning of January I'll do a video explaining
Civil War to.
You know the big twist behind it.
But there a lot of theories about how Tony
Stark is still around without actually being
around they just want him to seem like he's
not around anymore in the movies but I'm really
hoping for is like a brief moment if they
give her her powers vision style like he got
his powers during Avengers: Age of Ultron
that was kind of his origin story.
Hopefully during infinity war should get the
same type of treatment, but even in the movies
the Odin force is almost if not more powerful
than at least one infinity gem now assembling
the infinity gauntlet is a different story
because even if you have a gem you're very
powerful there so many characters that are
more powerful than you, but when you combine
gems there affects stack.
So imagine Doctor strange wielding the time
gem he's able to affect time on a relatively
planetary scale still a very, very big deal
but if he were to use that with the space
gem he would be able to change time for the
entire universe simultaneously.
So in the movies Captain Marvel versus vision
would be a relatively even fight the big difference.
There is an what's going on up in their heads
Captain Marvel is actually an alcoholic just
like Tony at least in the comics I'm hoping
they infuse a little bit of that pesos into
her movie character because one of the problems
with overpowered characters like Superman
in the DC universe is they need to have some
weakness.
Otherwise it just completely takes you out
of the story if you feel like they're invincible
and there's no conflict like vision superpowerful
with the mind gem.
But as he explains to scarlet which he doesn't
understand the gym fully and is kind of fighting
it at times.
So in the way the mind gem during the first
avengers film was able to cloud the minds
of lesser beings.
It also sounds like vision might have some
similar problems in the other big problem
is that if Thanos is going assemble the infinity
gauntlet that he's going to have to dismantle
vision to do that really big weakness right
there but the thing is is he is technically
artificial intelligence.
So you can separate visions mind from his
body.
His body can be repaired.
So he'll be okay.
He's like one of those characters that you
could crush into a tin can repair him later
and everything will be all right.
You can't really do that with the human character
without some hard-core medical technology
but aside from an infinity gem there just
aren't that many ways in the movies to make
Captain Marvel more powerful that people like
Thor or the whole.
So in the comics there were a couple human
characters that did get more powerful than
that, including Doctor doom.
Like I said during secret wars he became the
most powerful character in the universe for
brief.
But the problem is is the Doctor doom is typically
brought down by his own hubris.
That's a very Doctor doom type thing you gain
the power that you seek get your cripple by
your own sense of pride the reason that Doctor
doom became so powerful is because he was
infused with the collective power of the beyond
her's.
This extra dimensional race that the ability
to control the multi-verse but the big twist
was is that they only experience time in a
linear way so Doctor doom was able to travel
back along their timeline and defeat them.
So power abhors a vacuum.
Doctor strange is there with him and says
I don't want all this power.
I can't handle it.
It's too much, but Doctor doom who loves power
raises his hand instantly all take it so he
becomes the most powerful person in the marvel
universe and collects the fragments of all
the universes that are left over and turns
that into battle world, so is a really interesting
epic idea that the probably never get into
in the movies we just learned about the multi-verse
they haven't told that many cosmic stories
and Captain Marvel's origin in the comics
is relatively cosmic they change that to keep
her more Earth-based.
So you can see like the movies are really
trying to keep it as simple as possible but
just remember when Kevin Feige says that she
is the most powerful characters that they've
ever introduced in a movie that there are
characters that are more powerful than her
it is that they're leaving off that modifier
most powerful human character you know most
powerful character to come from earth.
So there a lot of cosmic entities that will
eventually show up in the marvel movies we
might even see death because she was a big
part of the Santos infinity gauntlet storyline,
so until one of the other avengers characters
wields the infinity gauntlet in the movies
she is technically the most powerful of venture
now but let me know in the comments if Captain
Marvel were to throw down with another avengers
character like they did in the first avengers
film we had Iron Man versus Thor we had Thor
hit Captain America's shield with his hammer.
What kind of moment like that do you want
to see with Captain Marvel's character when
she gets her powers and is filling there couple
characters like Doctor strange or the hold
that she could try to punch punching is really
one of her strengths she has energy blasts
but one of the big things in the Doctor strange
movie with that they wanted to get away from
people just standing away from each other
blasting each other with bolts of lightning.
So when we see Captain Marvel fighting what
you'll probably see is something really down
and dirty up close should be wrestling with
people like Holt or Panos like Captain Marvel
punching Thanos in the face of the really
awesome and in that way they might choose
to use her like Adam warlock during the original
infinity gauntlet storyline is that he was
sort of like the ultimate avenger during that.
So she might become the ultimate avenger during
the movies like you said big difference between
the movies in the comics Captain Marvel in
the comics is kind of like marbles version
of Superman, but there any other Marvel videos
that you guys want me to do from the comics
or the movies just let me know in the comments
be sure to subscribe to get everything I'll
be doing some epic battles videos in December
when a bunch of other TV stuff goes on break
will have a bunch of extra time so the be
some fun, comic book stuff happening in the
next month.
But this weekend, there's new Rogue one, so
do in a trailer video for that next, then
we have game of thrones and walking dead and
Westworld on Sunday will be posting updates
on my video schedule as I roll videos out,
but Rogue one will be next and I almost forgot
Final Fantasy XV is coming out next week to
if you want me to do a story video for that.
Just let me know in the comments while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for my Spider-Man homecoming carnage video
and you can click here to watch the big flash
arrow legends crossover trailer again.
Thank you so much watching I'll see you guys
in a couple hours!